et maintenant base double henkel cheikh
oussama ben laden sera payé par des
dissidents
ce soir accueille quelque il
le principe reste le même que ce qu'il
est au paquet killer je veux le nom de
l'interprète vous êtes prêt joey starr
didier
vous êtes très hardie si je veux
l'interprète 4 killer aux platines
numéro
pas
je mange jamais ans
bah
il
attention parfait numéro 2
oui
je veux dire vendée
joey starr prime browser lieu au stand
akram
merde
ça
abo ouais que tueur numéro 3
non
ce qui plaît encore chaud sur le banc
quand
non j'ai mis en bois quand j'étais petit
je viens famille jones qui serait lui
qui s'est fait charles non billy paul
oui
les gars
très bien merci no 4
ouais
v
il
non 5
mieux vaut pas le prix saint alary
et
merci que sans ce n'est tous en prison
tous mes collègues
et
avec de la neige c'est un poids pour
cette équipe et 4 coire et cela c'est
bien le temps passe et je suis avant
tout dépendrait beaucoup c'est chacun
pour sa gueule
attention au cut killer
à quand les machines uniques en mai
bien fait tu seras b
gvt style
lorsqu'un seul à trouver intentions
maintenant celui ou celle qui va trouver
le méga banco aura gagné le blind thèse
attention cut killer de renom
c est au point mort
ben voilà donc c'est gionta qui est le
grand vainqueur
je souhaitais spécial quelques couleurs
merci de killer